eq si vous aimez bien les arénas
francophone jean le même début pour les
arénas réel
mettez meta 1 pouces bleus on va essayer
de troll un peu ce tournoi comme on a
fait la semaine dernière c'était marrant
après on sait pas comment ça se passe
quand ton troll des fois ça se passe
dans une fois ça se passe mal voilà des
gens lui fait une kingfisher lui a donné
le pion à eux ont fait cavaliers en c6
et on va vouloir jouer tout en douceur
des six f6 développer le four on va
faire des six comme ça si on prend il me
prend on prend on se développe et et cif
ff4 en fera peut-être fou g4 pourquoi
pas et on ira se développer partout il
prend soin sont l'ajout à la nous qu'on
va reprendre du pillon peut-être où on
fait d'un f 6 ballons fed à 9,6 c'est
peut-être complètement n'importe quoi ce
que je fais si à 17 g fou prend sur fion
pranger dame prend et je couvre tout
mais là je menace dame prend b2 et s'il
fait cavalier ces trois grands rock
d'encaisser trois dames prend donc s'il
fait dames c'est un grand roque on
envoie puis en français 7 et je sais pas
on verra
ou peut-être s'il fait dame laon bon
voici faits d'armes là on voit en fait
on sait pas encore si on ne se
prononcent pas et je n'ai pas à me
prononcer sur ce coup ça m'intéresse pas
car celui-ci 3 + 2 ok donc ils protègent
leur dame prend b2 évidemment ça a l'air
bien mais écoutez je pense que l'esprit
ici c'est de faire un conte rock parce
que on a envie de on a envie d'être
sévère on a envie d'être très sévères
ici notre sévérité n'a pas d'égal
et notre célérité non plus d'ailleurs
très important d'être seiler tout en
étant sévère attention parce que
célérité ça commence par un c c'est pas
comme si l'air commence pareil ça va ça
faut le savoir
donc écoutez moi j'ai envie de partir
surprise en d6 comme ça si prendre
prendre la tour ya pas cavalier e 4
parce que el fahm au zoo clouage donc il
bouffe on bouffe et après on y va à fond
quoi donc là comme ça on va pouvoir
doubler les tours écoutez les amis on va
mettre le cavalier e set on va être bien
il va faire ses 3 on va faire [ __ ] en
f3 en premier il va refaire foot pro f 3
on va faire tour des huit et on va
encaisser l cavalaire et ciara espagnol
est à l'espagnol et et muchas gracias et
j'avoue gracias est elle si banga rien
hispania lucho gusto mucho gusta elle a
toréé d ocz autour des 8 et elle car à
l'aéro et des dos en d2 qui se fait des
dos en fait voilà qu'elle voit la fédé
les amis lecavalier en d2 qui se fait
des doses dont nous voyons là on à la
française made on a senti un française
man qui de base vont été assez dangereux
quand même 2300 sur czech comme mai mais
il se prend dix coups
donc voilà ça c'est un truc c'est
vérifiable il est complètement raide en
nicoud donc quand on sent la puissance
du trolling si vous voulez hein ça c'est
important
c'est à dire que là alors est-ce qu'on
fait tout reprend des deux ou pas parce
qu'on veut faire cavalier 5 et on est
des trolls dans l'âme on prend des
risques de partout et on va se prendre
peut-être dû d'amasha alors qu'havas
lieu cinq dames b3 qui est des trois
échecs roi ici qui a dépensé 1 prise
bessette roi des 7 je pense ça passe
donc on prend des risques
alors ça ne sert absolument à rien de
prendre ce risque là bien évidemment
c'est complètement débile mais c'est
dans le thème quelque part est-ce que
j'étais dans le thème oui je suis dans
le thème je suis dans le thème à fond
parce qu'il ya des trois sylvicoles
canon et au but de faire dame b trois
cavaliers échec si froide il y aura
cavaliers c5 et jusqu'à près des 2 donc
sera obligée de faire roi f-15 et
lycéens dame besset 3d cette dame b5 ces
six dames décès 3,8 et j'ai envie de
dire on fait du tai-chi tu vois non on
est pas mal et il n'y aura pas un petit
fou j'ai quatre échecs intermédiaire mon
prend des risques et on prend des
risques on part là dedans surtout prend
17 giroix b8 égal à dame qui a qui
attaque et donc ya pas deux découvertes
et sur d'un pro b c 3 17 bat c'est cool
parce que du coup c'est la vente dont on
parlait et ça permet à tout le monde de
la voir parce que c'est vrai que sinon
voilà alors là alors j'ai le choix entre
faire un truc qui doit gagner et faire
un truc de trolls qui peut perdre dans
sap r je peux patrol je voulais faire 3
au 6 mai c'est trop risqué on va faire
dame 5
on aurait pu voir une position plus
facile serait pas si on s'était pas
embarquer dans ce truc compliqué la saq
a eu 4 du coup j'avais pas vu ont sorti
deux variantes je me suis mis en
difficulté tout seul mais mais ça me
fait marrer donc tant mieux je refais
3/8 barré jeu peut-être m ah non je peux
pas mettre la dame en d2 je suis quand
même un peu mis en difficulté les mecs
bon je me suis un peu mis en difficulté
ça me fait un peu chier mais bon je
calcule assez mal en plus et il ya foule
de et je me suis mis dans la merde et je
perds le cavalier et je suis mal parce
que j'ai pas cavalier c'est 5 à cause de
tout reprendre et 6 et je me suis mis
très mal tout seul comme un idiot
écoutez c'est pas comme si c'était la
première fois que ça arrive et on va
essayer de s'en sortir mais en plus je
calcule très mal non je suis vraiment
mal en fait tout d'un coup j'ai une
mauvaise nouvelle je vais la perdre
j'ai une très mauvaise nouvelle je vais
la perdre les mecs les amis on est nuls
rage était super nul je vais la perdre
aïe aïe aïe pourquoi je suis allé trop
les autant olalalala voilà j'ai
complètement foutu du coup
c'est complètement perdant je suis super
écoeuré à yaya j'aurais dû la gagner
facile j'ai voulu j'ai voulu en faire
trop comme d'habitude j'ai voulu en
faire trop
complètement fou c'est tellement la
catastrophe cette position y'a juste
d'amd 4 f
aïe aïe aïe j'ai tellement une
catastrophe
rager fait nul à j'ai fait nul
qu'est-ce que je suis nul j'aurais trop
fait j'en ai trop fait j'aurais dû
bêtement francs dans des 2 1 et s'était
complètement fini direct en fait
j'aurais pu faire prix prise prise
prises et jusqu'à dieu 5 évoqué ces
chalets pour f3 menacé le pion f2 et
c'était fini direct mais j'ai voulu
trolls et ça n'a pas fonctionné
j'ai voulu rentrer indifférente
compliqué mais bon ça quand même un
petit intérêt pédagogique en fait dans
le sens vous ne rentrez jamais d'être
une position compliquée quand vous êtes
gagner en fait parce que la cave a lieu
quatre c'était très bien joué de sa part
et du coup bas mais en fait je suis
retrouvé dans une position c'est pas
facile le cavalier vraiment mal placé et
peut-être j'aurais dû faire caïds et 3
ça égaye ces cinq attaques et la dame
est sûre d'amis s'y faire c'est cissé
roi 8 et probablement j'aurais mieux
fait de jouer quelque chose comme ça
mais bon là on a voulu on dit qu'il y
avait chaque et mahata j'ai peut-être
raté un match les parrains mathias est
possible bon allez française man qui
était choix les lignes où le prochain
adversaire là c'est quoi c'est quoi ce
bordel j'ai envie de jouer là j'ai envie
de jouer à l'ailé tonton jambes on en
voit on en voit là les donnez moi des
adversaires allaient à 1000 allez on va
essayer d'y aller à la violente
on va donner des pions on va continuer à
donner du matos il prend pas le pion
passé c'est insupportable franchement
c'est arena ils te prennent jamais les
pions c'est horrible alors on a essayé
de laisser jouer ça comme ça et on va
envoyer les pions allait droit vous
allez voir ça va faire h6 ça s'est fait
flasher quatre affaires g5 1 on va faire
g5 quand même alors envoyé sur le roi
voilà qu'est ce que c'est que ça j'y
comprends rien fait je comprends rien à
ce coup parce que de toute façon je
voulais faire h5 le fou est de plus très
mal placé et maintenant je vais faire
j'ai quatre en plus je comprends juste
parce qu'il fait ok alors j'ai pas de
maths
malheureusement alors déjà je veux que
je peux troll en faisant un échec ou pas
non c'était quoi de mon coin en fait se
coupe si la fois je crois qu'il va
arriver par faut que j'arrête de troll
un moment donné bon je vais prendre ici
et je vais faire dame là ok et je veux
ça va pas marcher
je vais faire flouer qu'à tours h-13 h
inde à mach 6 et damages de maths mais
adama choix qui couvre sa va pas
fonctionner mais j'ai une position sympa
tosh j'ai peut-être eu qu'à faire genre
fou g50 f4 et je veux juste ok je vais
peut-être tour h4 ok alors ça marche pas
si je vous les meilleurs coups par
contre je le fais ou pas
et sans que ça marche pas il le voit ou
paris va le voir moi je vais faire un
grand roque
ok je fais retour g8
ah j'avais pas vu ça on n'est pas très
bien du coup j'ai raté ça a je rappe des
trucs pour le moment je rate des trucs
les ratés prix limite
bon je voulus mater vite comment ça
fonctionne pas un bon moment ils se
défendent
on tombe sur des joueurs costauds qui se
on va voir si ça se défend longtemps a
enfin enfin une gaffe y en avait marre
au bout d'un moment merde saga fait pas
enfin sa gaffe une pièce en un il y en
avait marre y en avait marre il y en
avait marre que ça gave pas ça faisait
pas d'erreur tout ça sari faisais pas
d'erreur il y en avait marre enfin une
pièce en un coup enfin un clouage enfin
assez de commencer à être insupportable
cet aréna j'en avais marre allait
redonner moins un adversaire là il y en
avait marre il y en avait marre des
amiga fait pas il n'ya fait pas du tout
j'en avais marre c'était là c'était plus
possible allez va faire 1h20 chigot
rinne a alors la c3 un petit peu étrange
bon ça se joue un mais attendez ce qui
me copient là encore il est en train de
copier j'ai été obligé de faire un truc
pour sortir deux aces que si je donne
une dame en a une copie encore ou pas
i'm copie tiens je fais car il sait
comment tu vas faire car au lieu de ça
fait moins le malin là on fait moins le
malin alors c'est qui le patron c'est
qu'il patron maintenant que j'ai mille
cavaliers e set
c'est qui le patron et bouble cavaleur
f5 et boum lecavalier ont des six
caisses qui se passe je viens de faire
quatre coups de cavaliers toi tu
attendais ou qu'est ce tu fais regarde
le cas je suis là non je suis là bim g5
aller
[Musique]
bein je te prends ton cavaliers le tien
y survit pas bhimjee par an ces quatre
ans mais regarde ce cavalier regardez
moi ces cavaliers c'est plus un cavalier
c'est c'est un génie pur il était là il
a fait quoi il a fait ça ça ça et ça
j'ai envie de te dire c'est un ninja et
dim
il prend le pion mais c'est un génie
regardez regardez moi ça regardez la
partie qui fait il fait il fait tout
tout seul il fait tout le cavalier il
fait tout
j'ai envie de te dire tu as un cavalier
comme ça si tu gagnes pas c'est la honte
une fantastique ce cavalier qui a déjà
eu un cavalier comme ça dans une partie
qui a déjà pu avoir un cavalier comme ça
dans une partie mais personne personne
n'a jamais eu un cavalier de ce calibre
à l'ebit mach 5 comme ça je le fais
revenir angers 4 ans mais ce cavalier
pour rien au monde je te le donne
franchement c'est l'homme du match man o
man of the match c'est florian thauvin
mais voilà el magnifico florian thauvin
mais attendez jamais j'ai eu un cavalier
comme ça dans ma vie c'est le premier
quoi attendez vous allez voir on va s'y
fait h4 on va faire cavalier trois
cavaliers f5
on va tout lui faire avec ce cavalier
qui essayent de copier ils essayent de
choper un car elle aussi alors ça c'est
bien joué par contre
avec quoi je vais lui montrer que les
cavaliers c'est plus fort que les tours
[ __ ] c'est quand même tellement de la
merde j'ai par un bon allez
faut pas trop y penser quoi je me
déteste quand je fais ce genre de truc à
les lecavalier plus fort que la tour
alors à lui prouvé ce cavalier beaucoup
plus fort qu'une tour on assume on
assume ce qu'on dit de partir par là ok
ok quand un cavalier comme ça tu as peur
de personne
c'est plus fort qu'un cavalier c'est un
janus
regarde moi ça regarde moi ce cavalier
ils attaquent tout ils attaquent tous
ils attaquent tous et c'est plus un
cavalier c'est un génie qu'est ce qui au
regard il défend encore la non mais
attends c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable non mais il est super fort il
a tout fait il a tout fait dans la
partie il a fait quoi il est il et il
est parti on va envoyer les pions ils
étaient où il a fait çà çà çà çà çà çà
çà çà çà çà çà et ça non mais attendez
franchement
c'est exceptionnel c'est exceptionnel
c'est exceptionnel c'est extraordinaire
c'est extraordinaire il est vraiment il
est vraiment il est vraiment phénoménal
il est monstrueux ce cavalier c'est un
pur génie c'est un pur sang âgés gerra
j'ai rarement vu ça
il va absolument il veut absolument s'en
débarrasser ça incroyable c'est
incroyable il veut vraiment s'en prendre
à mon cavalier 1 c'est c'est
insupportable
c'est insupportable au nom il le prend
au nom il le prend au nom au nom
je suis écoeuré ah je suis écoeuré ils
jouent pas le jeu il joue pas le jeu
soleil tout rouge a commencé celle
d'avoir fait ça comment ils n'avaient
pas le droit de le prendre mais comment
il va le payer cher ça ça ça se paye
soleil rouge payes tu est ruiné tu est
ruiné t'avais pas le droit de faire ça
tu avais pas le droit de faire ça soleil
tout rouge
t'avais pas le droit maintenant mange
mon courroux quoi tu avais pas loin de
prendre c'était mon cavalier qua non
mais attends voilà abou madi dégagea les
obsolète où j'allais apprendre veux plus
te voir
incroyable c'est incroyable ça à bandol
incroyable ça
ce cavalier aller et anne à ce cavalier
de génie que j'avais je vous avais dit
je le sentais chose cavaliers quant à un
cavalier comme ça honnêtement tu te sens
dessus de tout ça l'uab larqué ou ce qui
est la halle et bim
josé dias cavalier était plus fort
qu'une tour on l'a senti non vous l'avez
senti dans le chat est ce qu'est ce que
l'on le chat vous avez senti la
puissance de ce cavalier ou pas ou pas
du tout par là on va faire ressortir la
tour parages 3 attention et si vous avez
senti sa puissance nettement après un
personne me répond ah tu casses à agnant
sur les tanins ne connaît pas ouais tu
ne connais pas faire attention on révise
ses classiques
ok on va en profiter pour faire un petit
coup de ces quatre pour commencer
c'est peut-être pas terrible c'est 4°
fait refouler 5
et je voulais jouer ici demain mais ça
marche pas ouais bah écoutez j'ai de
nouveau une position pourri parce que la
france et 4 on va écouter on va être
obligés de
je la sens pas trop ça là je la sens pas
trop les amis les amis on est mal
on est mal les amis on va voir on va
voir alors ce que ça donne je la sens
pas trop mal et on va continuer dans
l'esprit à fond c'est tellement peur de
jeu dans l'esprit je vais dans l'esprit
sur quelque chose qui fait peur même
pour un apôtre du beau jeu comme moi
parce que si vous voulez l'esprit fait
peur je vais dans l'esprit c'est un
devoir mais c'est aussi c'est un droit
mais ce sont aussi des devoirs
et du coup c'est vrai que des fois tu ta
suite arrive plus à assumer si tu veux
le fait de jouer dans l'esprit des fois
je me regarde dans la glace je me lève
le matin je me dis est ce que est ce que
si tu veux je suis encore assez forts
pour envoyer des pièces en un comme ça
et jouer d'henri jouer et jouer dans
l'esprit à fond ça je me dis est ce que
j'ai encore la légitimité jouer comme ça
non en fait je le dis jamais franchement
je ne dis pas franchement non
franchement jeudi envoie des pièces fait
de la merde tu seras toujours légitimes
quoi franchement je me pose jamais la
question
bon on a envoyé une pièce mais on a
foutu le bordel on joue contre un gamin
du coup contre les gamins foutent le
bordel c'est pas une bonne idée parce
qu'ils aiment bien le bordel
normal on a foutu quand même un énorme
bordel risque qui va s'en sortir mieux
que moi truc c'est qu'il est gagnant là
mais mais bon en traître gagnant et
gagner parfois le chemin est long en
tout cas il est mal autant mais elle
rajoute temps qui peut le sauver
pas de chance mais j'ai foutu le bordel
il ya des pièces de partout j'ai décidé
de venir en g8 est avec la dame et je
crois qu'en fait tout marche pour lui
tout est acquis que je que je calcule
pas vraiment marche pour les noirs mais
j'ai foutu un bordel monstre est fou
prend ça m'a l'air plutôt pas mal de sa
part je prends une fois ici je prends
une autre fois là
c'est chaud là bas rhin depuis qu'elle
fait c'est fou ces trois dames g8 3
cette dame à 8
ok mais là je peux peut-être faire juste
3 prends et je fais du tai-chi j'ai la
dame qui protège le cavalier lecavalier
qui protège la tour atx malin comme un
singe suis pas très bien quand même tu
vois mais on est quand même mal
c'est vraiment catastrophique de j'ai
des positions pourri comme ça
malgré cet effort intense je suis mal
c'est tellement injuste
les échecs sont injustes
la vie est injuste
j'ai tellement mal joué je devrais avoir
le droit d'avoir une bonne position
quand même aux grands esprits au grand
esprit me sera tu reconnais sans gène
locke là dsk y ça pour qu'elle me donne
une position gagnante au grand dsk is à
toutes les offrandes de beau jeu mais
permettront-elles d'avoir une position
plus convenable j'implore la
reconnaissance bon écoute et j'implore
j'importe la reconnaissance j'ai fait
une finale complètement insipide mais
j'ai pas envie quoi enfin laissez moi
jouer une bonne partie quoi y'en a marre
à la fin je met à l'amendé et 6
ils veulent pas mais c'est jouer mes
adversaires sont chiants club
mais pénible des tanins fins franchement
non mais c'est insupportable honnêtement
c'est insupportable tendance à échanger
les dames c'est incroyable
honnêtement c'est insupportable
c'est pas très bien joué ça d'ailleurs à
honnêtement les enfants c'est
insupportable suis-je le seul à pau
troupe du beau jeu ici bas
très chouette perdant quoi
aïe aïe aïe sur le sol apôtre du beau
jeu quoi agacer la catastrophe ada les
amis c'est la catastrophe à la c'est la
catastrophe annales beau jeu bat f
allait prendre le pion à 7 et et la
jouer mais bon le beau jeu ne
l'emportent pas le beau jeu ne
l'emportent pas très difficile ce soir
très difficile le beau jeu n'est pas
récompensé dans ce tournoi le beau jeu
n'aura pas payé et al
le beau jeu n'aura pas payé le beau jeu
ne paye pas c'était pas loin de payer
quand même hein mais bon un jour est
venu faire un peu moins le beau jeu je
vais laisser le cahier contre le pion
après mais bon le beau jeu est trop
juste ce soir comme quoi y'a des jours
il est récompensé à des jours les mois
bien joué et anne ce qu'il ya de plus en
plus de mal ce soir un peu loin que beau
jeu que ce soit dans la première partie
ou dans celle là on aurait dû couper un
peu plus tôt mois et on est récompensé
quand même contre poule pinatar on va
lancer notre mental alors
est-ce que ça a payé un peu mieux dans
celle là peut-on encore rejoindre le
toit oui bien sûr un jeu parce que
quelqu'un peut mettre un lien dans le
tchat
qu'est ce que c'est que ça et
abandonnent tout le pin à tort enfin à
l'épaule pin à tort la caisse qui me
fait pour pina tort une dame de moins
ils jouent
peut-être mieux payés dans celle là va
repartir repartir de l'avant
alors
farid est connecté il est déconnecté
maïs et déconnecté
pin à tort que nous faire payer notre
notre position il va falloir en gagner
une autre
non mais pas me jouer ça quand même là
qu'est ce que c'est que ça je me fais
trop lu par tout le monde
voilà allaient les abandonner grave à
tort à faire eux cinq près vous allez
gravatar alegre a tort prend le pion va
pas le prendre
asim ainsi le prend maintenant je pense
que ça n'a pas du tout pour moi quoi
c'est la catastrophe haddad et amis ont
peur de rien quoi c'est pas possible ils
n'ont plus peur quoi c'est horrible il
n'y a plus aucun respect c'est aurait pu
leur donne des pions il est près de
maintenant il n'y a plus de respect sur
ses arénas n'y a plus de respect les
amis c'est de pire en pire c'est de pire
en pire c'est de pire en pire ses arénas
devient de plus en plus insupportable
il ya me prendre ma pièce ils prennent
tout un ca ils prennent tout ils
prennent tous assez insupportable tu
leur donnes des pièces en haïti les
prennent tu leur donnes des pions il et
prennent ils prennent tout tout tout
tout tout c'est des morts de faim c'est
insupportable insupportable on s'en sort
plus on s'en sort plus ah oui c'est
quand même à mettre un petit échec sympa
tosh on va prendre ce pion ça peut être
sympa touche aussi
on va prendre suis là maintenant
peut se faire planter quand même hein
c'est un poil dangereux non mais ils
échangent les dames et y'en a marre mais
ils échangent tous les dames mais pousse
tous tous quand était le dernier mec qui
n'a pas voulu échanger les dames contre
nous c'est pas possible
ils échangent tout le temps les dames
tout le temps tout le temps et sur dame
sicilia d'alger 3 je suis désespéré les
mecs je suis désespéré quel monstre est
créé ils échangent tous les dames
c'est dur tout le monde échange les dab
c'est monstrueux ce sont des monstres du
patient à aulas là ils échangent tout
olala c'est une telle catastrophe ils
échangent toutes les pièces qui peut
quoi c'est impressionnant on est mal là
quand même
on est très mal les mecs
je crois qu'on va vraiment la perdre
aussi bien je crois qu'on va tous perdre
les mecs
sûr qu'on va tous perdre les mecs m'ont
l'air de sa manière de toujours passer
pour eux la merci bobby fischer au nom
il a trouvé le bon coup ah c'est la
catastrophe
il trouve tout il trouve tout il trouve
tout
n'at il joue bien qu'elle voulait
ce que vous voulez tant mieux pour eux
ils jouent bien ils jouent bien
qu'est-ce qu'on peut y faire prend là
qu'est ce que c'est bien joué ça aussi
il vient attaquer mon pions ouais non
mais je vais abandonner un je vais
abandonner les mecs sains
ouais ça joue bien ce soir il se bat
bien ça c'est encore bien joué il ya
rien à dire ils méritent leur victoire
tous ça la vie hein pas toujours gagner
c'est comme ça ce soir ils se vengent
du coup je commence à comprendre un peu
la dose c'est en fait de monter la dose
de deux handicaps en trop long et la bce
et là je crois que c'est bien joué ça
aussi ouais ils menacent tous réfutent
mat
vous avez vu mais je pensais qu'il
verrait pas d'avoir des formes comme ça
il joue bien il joue bien
mais bon va t'il quand même la gagner ce
qui s'est pas lancé dans des tactiques
trop compliqué pour lui assez bien joué
attendez
tendez second la aïnats venu il a vu il
l'a vu mais c'est insupportable c'est
insupportable j'en peux plus je n'en
peux plus les mecs ils voient tout il
voit tout mais est ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir jusqu'au bout et ce qui va
craquer
tu va craquer tu va craquer là je pense
qu'il va craquer bah je pense qu'en fait
ça va pour moi il va pas prendre il va
faire ou abbaye six tours bekkat échec à
cravate or ont su heures aux graves à
tort en sueur elle était jolie la
tactique finale elle était jolie la
vente de fin était joli tour g7 pour
prendre b2 je pense quoi ces trois
forces et tours b 3 prend ses quatre
tours ses trois échecs roi mais qu'at-il
veut éviter les échecs pas se prendre un
dame sur échec
et finalement il se fait mettre en sueur
par trouver 4 à c'était une jolie fin de
partie ah ça valait le coup trop les
rimes pour avoir ça à la petite tactique
et a fini truc à elle a fait place à on
a en a on a abusé pour avoir ce genre de
trucs et le lien killer qui leur allait
au pire on a pas mal abusé on a réussi à
finir avec une très jolie tactique serge
pour la faire en exercice pour mes
courses à l'aller elle était mignonne
n'a été très mignonne celle là
c'est pour ça à contrôler ça mérite un
puzzle rush sérieux elle était jolie
sérieuses et pour dc pour des tactiques
comme ça qu'on se met mal c'est pour
faire des tld tel truc joli 100 m quand
tu joues normal tu as moins de choses
jolies qui arrive quand tu joues un peu
bizarre tu vois tu as des genre de
tactique comme ça qui arrive à la fin
sérieux cette tactique là elle récupère
récupère tout le reste on peut pas jouer
si on est sur smartphone malheureusement
soir elle a tout récupéré cela a tout
récupéré
et j'ai failli abandonner mais j'étais
mal j'étais mal un sérieux j'avais pas
vu en fait que je pouvais faire autant
de tchic tchac avec la tour et avec la
tour j'avais pas vu les mecs j'avais pas
vu
je pense qu'il va venir sacrifier laon
ont donné
on chasse le cavale il recule et on
chasse à noter deux victoires jeunes
curieux quatre ans prises c'était pas
volontaire
enfin c'est pas forcément très
volontaire j'étais plutôt en train de
penser à la tactique c'est pas nous
votons plein air voilà en fait c'est pas
sûr monstre ima s'escrime 13 points
comme tonton tonton d'excellents là
c'est le stream cher.com du coup c'est
pas mon stream
donc du coup je mets des temples est qu
on me dit de mettre un tu sais
mais bon faut que je crois qu'une fois
par partie en fait je pense contrat les
joueurs plus forts contre ajoie au
dessus de 2001 seuls troll contre les
autres 2 mai contre les joueurs à plus
de 2 min faut faire un seul troll peu
trop les l'ouverture mais après faut
plus trop les sites hurtrel une deuxième
fois en milieu de jeu comme on l'a fait
contre et année contre eux et contre
française man ça passe plus ils ne
savent ne tolère pas de troll
voilà ça joue pour le moment allez allez
citron chocolat on accélère un peu
allez allez plus vite que ça citron
chocolat
une chanson là un peu bizarre chocolat
je suis puisque c'était chaud chaud
chaud chocolat a enfin on tend un piège
et ben voilà qui est bien temps de
pousser 5 pour me faire une découverte
tu sais que tu seras tu peux tu auras un
guide d ouverture aux débutants bas sur
ma chaîne youtube
salut à françois jacq ah on me dit que
je joue vraiment super bien aux échecs
et bien merci tonton
ça fait plaisir ça surtout
qu'aujourd'hui joue pas très bien mais
bon tu avec je troll beaucoup mardi j'ai
pas mal joué a title tuesday j'arrive
pas trop à calculer la j'espère ça c'est
usant de mettre des positions aussi
bordélique
mais c'est juste s'en prendre à ça qu'on
va s'en prendre à ça et on va faire dame
c'est sa voix comme ça on a un peu
éclairci jeu je dirais voilà on a
échangé on a tout est changé en l'espace
de deux coups allez on continue à
remonter à les jeux je vais gagner
l'aréna ah ouais donc lui je sens jeu
sans danger je vais gagner l'aréna a
laissé hobby fischer a way me joue cette
vente la samsung y en a marre je
connaissais un truc marrant contre ça
mais je me rappelle plus trop
est-ce que ça transposerait pas dans une
variante normal ça je crois qu'il a
transposé je crois que ça transpose
salle françoise un truc que je connais
ça a transposé dans la vente normal en
fait
marrant j'ai pas si koné du coup je vais
gagner l'aréna on lui demandera oui
c'est parce qu'en fait il a fait une
transposition la vente normal une grille
clinique éminent conseil demain je vais
dans les régionaux championnat de france
un conseil à me donner
le conseil s'est restent bien concentrés
soient déterminés ne se dispersent pas
sûr déterminés à gagner tu as un
objectif c'est gagner les autres ne sont
là que pour perdre en fait enfin les
autres sont là pour décorer en fait toi
tu es là pour gagner très important donc
en fait l'idée deux à trois c'est
d'empêcher dame b4 bon je le dis c'est
50 euros vous dit charles à le conseil
donc h600 fait ça c'est pas trop dans le
plan mais tu ne dois 50 balles tu ne
dois 50 bas le bobby fischer je prends
carte bleue paypal espèces tu avais
compris non mais tu dois 50 balles quand
même c'est à dire que voilà c'est faut
savoir donc bobby fischer qui me doit 50
balles ben écoute merci bobby fischer
merci moby plus 50 euros pour tonton
cave toujours agréable sa part assez
stream tu te fais un peu d'argent
passage moi je dis ça le fait
ok ça va se placer un peu
on va voir comment ça évolue
alors
solide pour le moment et mettre le dawa
f4 pour le moment il est solide
ok on va prendre une fois on va revenir
avec une tour quand même il est solide
un ce mobile fischer enfin prendre de
l'espace y est solide
j'aime pas les gens solides père père
l'appareil
j'ai vraiment solide il est fort
j'aurais peut-être faire dame eu 3
je suis un peu raté peut-être essayer de
passer par là bas tant mieux c'est bien
que ces enfants progressent ils
regardent les stream il progresse jeu
plutôt content ce sont mes enfants
quelque part est humaine fils fait très
attention car ce sont les enfants
mais bon j'ai créé des monstres je
n'arrive même plus à les battre c'est
des frankenstein quoi je n'aurais je ne
réussis pas à abattre mes propres bêtes
quoi ils sont devenus incontrôlables
même pour l'heure pour pour leurs
créateurs c'est très attention ne jouez
jamais contre eux beaucoup trop
dangereux dégage alors ils sont devenus
forts en fait ces gamins-là fouchy quoi
rien a marre non mais c'est vrai tu fais
des strings et machin tu dis ne
progresserons jamais ils seront toujours
complètement nu et puis en fait non les
mecs progresse moi j'avais voulu qu'ils
progressent 1 je voulais qu'il reste nul
ouais c'est pénible
je passe qui a 4 c'était une bonne idée
j'ai un peu provoc est là et c'est bien
ce que je pensais il revient à non mais
y en a marre je vous ai jamais demandé
de bien jouer
jamais fait les stream pour que vous
jouiez bien aux échecs moi j'ai un
objectif c'est vous soyez nul quoi faire
arrêter quoi alors écoutez je sais pas
trop comment taire s'agit pas d' idées
qui me viennent
je vais faire ça mais j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit très bon
acpg catm sens il faut pas faire d'amour
en 8 en même temps et l'autre café sens
incroyable quoi marie sont
insupportables j'en ai marre de ces cas
mais je ne veux plus jouer contre ces
fines dorénavant les inscriptions sont
fermées aux joueurs à plus de 2000 - ce
sera simple non mais c'est vrai c'est le
stream tranquille macha et on se fait
martyriser par des gamins de 14 piges
quoi ça va s'abaisser bien joué en plus
s'en passer vraiment bien joué mais faut
féliciter un il fait une bonne partie
je vais je vais pas le battre je pense
pas je veux être même perdre bon alors
est il temps madame froid je crois qui
est vraiment bien je crois mais je vais
tenter un truc plus drôles ou à l'ailé
temps de troll un peu assez moitié troll
ce que je pense que c'est un bon coup
mais bon il est temps d'essayer de
gagner avec style
est ce que je fais cavaliers f6 direct
ouais ça va leur champ mais ça il est
temps de gagner avec style contre cet
enfant en le clouant pas mais moralement
d'affaires des efforts attend ça va
penny s'égare pas possible allez enfin
on le max à ce sont des monstres ce sont
des monstres je n'en peux plus je n'en
peux plus les amis je n'en peux plus
laissez moi tranquille laissez moi vivre
laissez moi un livre je veux vivre il y
avait une chanson comme ça je veux vivre
à nom est marc non inscrits au tournoi
bobby fischer ii enfin si c'est pour
jouer comme ça et me et me poser autant
de problèmes sérieux on prend aucun
plaisir
on prend aucun plaisir si c'est pour
bien jouer comme ça franchement on ne
revient plus jouent mal tu as tu viens
tu joues mal tu joues mal c'est tout
c'est horrible j'ai même pas trop le
contre toi non mais je sais bobby
fischer je m'étais dit je vais moins
drôles de mecs et fort la bobby fischer
je me méfie toi je me suis méfié toi
j'ai flairé c'est ça hein ça sent le mec
dangereux car j'ai tout de suite senti
et du coup j'ai fait le coup je me suis
dit lui je le troll pas et j'ai bien
fait parce que tu es hyper pénible mais
mais je vais dire ça te rendra pas
service à un des parents je sais pas ils
savent que tu comme ça tu tient tête aux
adultes
tu crois que c'est beau de tenir tête
aux adultes comme samedi fischer tu
crois que c'est bien tu crois que tu es
parents vont être fiers de toi
attends moi je vais être cadré je vais
te le dire tout de suite moi je te
recadre par la feccom frosty france
disent ils mais sont fous en dessin qui
me laisse faire une petite double
attaque je gagnais sont fous voilà ça
s'est bien passé quand même incroyable
c'est quand même incroyable non mais
attends une éducation de nos jours on
tient tête à des adultes non mais j'ai
jamais vu ça j'ai jamais vu ça à ces
mioches alors supportable je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez dans le chat si vous
avez des gamins mais j'espère que c'est
ça abandonne un petit peu plus vite que
ça quand même un petit peu plus vite
possible ça et ethan qui la ramène en
plus aux normes et attendait les enfants
là ça va ça va mal se passer là un
salarié en plus il veut une tuyère honte
avec à 3 non mais attends non mais
attends bobby fischer ii incroyable ça
incroyable étudier et étudier ça ça va
vouloir aller faire ses études à paris
c'est encore non mais attends attends
des deux petites minutes là quand même
ah je vous jure ça à vouloir à monter à
la capitale sa gloire monte à la
capitale pour faire ses études
non mais attends tu vas aller travailler
dans les champs moi je te le dis tout de
suite ça va pas ça ne va pas aller bien
loin à cette histoire là quelle
insolence insolence et enfants insolent
faites très attention à l'état ne
naissait pas te mettre sous le coup de
l'humour n'essaye pas de te mettre sous
le coude d'humour attention attention un
jeu lettres recadrer tout ça moi est ce
qu'il ya des adultes dans le chatt
d'ailleurs je sens qu'il ya plus
d'adultes ya plus rien il ya ya ya ya
plus de ya plus d'autorité n'a plus
d'autorité plus de respect
heureusement il ya des adultes j'espère
que ça vaille aux grains vous voyez un
petit peu ce que ce qui nous attend
alors l'ami frost 10 bon allez j'en ai
marre de frost nice line est sympa frost
10 kg a pas de souci avec ça on est très
amis avec toi mais au bout d'un moment
tu as une pièce de moins tu nous fait
traîner on est loin dans l'aréna là on
remonte pas du tout on va on va pas on
va pas pouvoir remonter ces les
appariements bien évidemment ça vaut le
savoir ça va abandonner évidemment de ne
pas aimer mais pose des problèmes plus
un qui me respecte moi c'est fini a
tellement plu respect dans ses arènes
olala il menace même des me dit fonder
menaçant d'un coup
aie aie aie aie aie aie aie pas et c'est
avec suprema sion ne rattrapera pas on
rattrapera passé avec ses prix mincir
il n'y a pas un matelas qui rôde
on espérait qu'ils rien on ne sait pas
d'où l'impression qui a rien à lille
progressent 1 il progresse mais je veux
plus faire de stream en fait les stream
c'est une mauvaise idée s'adresse à la
salle et ça les aide à bien jouer les
stream après ils apprennent deux mois
ils voient comment je fais machin la
manière de penser je vais arrêter ou
alors veut dire que de la merde je veux
dire que des conneries mais les streams
match donnait une dame en un c'est bien
bon ça fait déjà fait mais bon un peu
dans cet esprit là tu annonces maintient
la tourache de très mauvais coup
l'avenir
tu vois je commence quand je commence
dès maintenant qu'il réussisse beaucoup
plus forte
tia faut faut être malin faut être malin
faux faux pu leur dire allez les bons
coups tu tu me tiens je veux 4g ce
cavalier cas ce qu il faut être plus
malin que faut être plus malin que faut
arrêter de leur donner des infos
j'arrête
c'est une question d'un coup serait
intelligent a fait chanter partie tarifs
rejoue contre moi tout à fait bien qu'à
faux faux faux faux les avoir la
sournoise tu les avants la sournoise
dois je te le dis tout de suite
regarde moi je suis obligée de faire
tour eiffel tu vois j'ai plus trop le
choix pour la gagner mais ça non ça
c'était très mauvais coup tour est fait
rage j'ai fait une faute merde j'aurais
beaucoup mieux fait de faire roi b5
pas de chance pas de chance à l'appui on
prend pas masquer l grosse erreur tu as
faux faut être malin je vais plus malin
que maintenant de façon telle c'est fini
je suis plus malin qu'eux puisque cette
position et gagne ensuite nul toriques
bon c'est pas
je n'ai aucune idée
bourbourg duhamel fais pas ce que je
fais je joue sur l'aisne tient très
bonne idée je fais une nouvelle
ouverture
je bouge sur les côtés tu vois et je
sens les tours de côté et après je jeu
convergent vers le centre
je mange le manges tu vois je mange de
côté alors ça tout ça tout ça prenait la
note et and not to rage 6 très fort
après j'ai des pions doublé sur le côté
c'est très bien la linotte états unis
prend bout de papier note le regarde
jouer des coudes autour de côté tu avais
dit je vais t'apprendre les échecs moi
tu vois tu as je t'apprends les échecs
se soit intéressé léthargie développe
aucune pièce que tu tes pieds sur la
huitième c'est beaucoup plus fort
l'exploit a transmis de six pièces
uniques a surpassé coiffe
fmb sur elle beaucoup plus forts qui ont
doublé sur la colonnade ce serait le
ferai mais bon il n'a pas laissé faire
bon non mais ça y est j'ai compris mes
ancêtres ça que tous les stream ça va
être ça soit 120 ses phares aux habitués
il n'y aura plus un plus un stream
différents jeux
je ne suis plus du tout intéressé par le
fait de les aider à progresser c'est
fini
défini j'ordonne plus un conseil je vous
conseillerais plus jamais allait arriver
dans vos clubs à jouer dans vos clubs
apprenez les faux échec à l'effet défini
moi j'ai donné je suis pas venu ici pour
souffrir ok j'en ai marre
peut-être qu contre cartonnera quand
même écart ça n'a rien à faire moi je ne
veux plus je veux plus être rebaptisé
par ethan et part et par bobby fischer 2
j'en ai marre j'en ai marre j'en ai ma
claque des deux là les 2 mio chf maquis
qui font chier le monde sont devenues
trop fort c'est fini qu'est-ce qui fait
nuit
alors
qui n'ont rien fait enfin concrètement
là je comprends pas ce qui se passe
enfin ce puzzle roche tey là non je suis
là donc voilà très bien le développement
de côté on a vu sa puissance
on a vu la puissance du quai du du
développement de côté a laissé bien
apprenez apprenez les enfants
apprenaient
allez apprenez les enfants apprenaient
apprenez on apprend on apprend parce que
c'est ça mais pas l'air terrible dates
des 6 alors
mais je sortir les mouchoirs y en a qui
jette a pris in advance est bien établie
grâce un revenu dit j'ai moins paniqués
mais il faut paniquer bourrique
il faut paniquer ils paniquent plus ils
sont fiers c'est incroyable mais c'est
incroyable mais j'en peux plus quand
j'en peux plus de ces gens je suis
ruinée j'en ai marre j'en ai marre les
amis les amis ils sont insupportables à
ils sont insupportables
y en a marre y en a marre y en a marre
allez hop ça c'est mieux
enfin quelqu'un qui nous fait des
vacances
bon il fallait la gagner celle là quand
même
il fallait la gagner les amis bien et
vite fait c'est gagner en quoi ces gars
lyon d'où ce coup on a fait un peu de
tactique
un avocat et une en tue peu la joue et
ça c'est cool parce que yanis a été plus
sympa quoi que les autres donc ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle à leyment d'aix les
trucs qui finissent par le x comme ça à
la fin ça me fait penser à autre chose
hélas qui sait plaisir c'est qu'on peut
se parler entre adultes voilà donc
lorsqu'on prend entre adultes à c'est
pour ça que justement ce à quoi je te le
dis je ne te dis pas tu n'as tu ne le
saura jamais là ça va ça fait plaisir
merci les amis heureusement qu'il ya des
adultes dans le tchat
heureusement qu'on n'est pas encore seul
je souffle je souffle de nouveau les
amis
je souffle de nouveau
ken chen et comprend compris est battu
mais il se trouve que j'ai vécu dans le
canton de genève
donc là donc tu fais très attention dans
le canton de genève y apparaître le mot
qui finissent par os x mais comme comme
la ville de ggfx jet qui ne se lit pas
gex d'ailleurs est donc là du coup alors
à toi à quelques couacs quoi tu penses
et ethan moi je moi je pensais âgées
dans l'ain une ville très intéressant
d'ailleurs un petit château il ya il ya
même un fromage le bleu de g pour ceux
qui pour ce qui est qu'ils ne
connaissent pas donc voilà alors après
est ce que est ce que l'état n'aurait
l'esprit mal placé on ne sait pas mais
ça m'étonnerait pas ça m'étonnerait pas
qu'on soit sur des gens qui ont un qui
ont un esprit complètement complètement
déplacé ça ça nous étonnerait pas envie
de dire ah c'est pas mal joué dans
repris en effet si ça joue bien c'est
insupportable
ethan qui abandonnent bon alors
parce que des gens qui connaissent j'ai
laissé les gens qui connaissent g ou là
là on a cliqué sur des trucs je sais pas
s'il ya des gens qui voyageait dans le
chat c'est pas super connu bon alors
comment on fait on va faire mal et on va
faire des 5 rbds et 4 ça marche matin ça
marche c'est pas terrible terrible
d'affaires prison a fait retour c'est 8
tu vas faire pousser 5 va faire à 5
étoiles et les gens en suisse qui
connaît ce sujet c'est fantastique de
bungie est ce que tu as déjà mangé du
boeuf du bleu de j'ai dit mais ce qu'il
ya des gens qui ont mangé du bleu des
bas mais c'est pas possible je clique
sur le tchad je me retrouve sur des
liens bon alors que ça donne cette
position est ce que c'est si bien que ça
pour les blancs suis pas sûr je crois
que c'est pas terrible terrible ça pour
les blancs franchement franchement j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas le rêve là
pour mon texte sur son mandat qui se
fait raser
y a pas abandonné bien évidemment à aïn
abandonne jamais hein
il n'abandonne jamais c'est incroyable
enfin je rappelle même plus que ça veut
dire abandonnez quoi plus personne à
personne d'avoir une contrebasse et
c'est fantastique
incroyable incroyable c'est incroyable
j'ai quand même gagnants à la non
rassurez moi
rassurez-moi les amis je suis gagnant là
je suis même plus sur l'agencé plus rien
force de ne pas abandonner j'en sais
plus rien je vais laisser les cavaliers
envie j'en sais plus rien ils
n'abandonnent plus du coup je sais même
plus si je suis gagnant ou pas allez
matiz astier est ce qu'il ya un rapport
avec oeuf
alexandre astier j'en veux dire on ne
sait pas alors
alors mais ils sont durs à ce soir
franchement c'est dur franchement ce
soir c'est dur ce soir ici mais tous cas
ils sont ils sont ligués contre moi ils
se sont ligués contre moi et ça je le
sais j'en peux plus je n'en peux plus je
n'en peux plus j'en peux plus du tout il
y en a marre à y en a marre j'en peux
plus ils sont vraiment là pour se moquer
de moi quoi c'est insupportable c'est oh
non non non non voulait pas jouer ça
pas j'en ai marre j'en ai superbe
c'est insupportable j'ai un super mars
insupportable pour jeunes à rennes c'est
par ici
malgré vous en fait c'était pas si
mauvais bizarrement mais là ça on est
une pièce de plus en fait bon allez faut
continuer remonte à da il y en a marre
les amis
oh non non non c'est la catastrophe
c'est la catastrophe les amis c'est la
catastrophe
c'est la catastrophe on n'a même pas
drôle on n'a même pas trop long on a
juste donné une pièce en un olalala
insupportable c'est insupportable on a
de nouveau donné une pièce en main c'est
la catastrophe
juste pas la moindre idée de quoi jouer
ici j'aime pas une once d'idées
petit n'est vraiment dur là
pessiot n'est vraiment pas facile ici
les bons tours gâte c'est peut-être pas
très bien senti
il faut se battre 1 c'est tellement dur
s exprime ainsi qui s'échappe quand on
ne rattrapera pas assez bien joué sans
plus on est vraiment mal à rennes on
gagnera pas le tour noire
enfin pas si mal joué pourtant pas si
mal joué
5 avec un gros lots il faut vraiment
tout gagné 1 à séduire ses arènes c'est
dur
ouais faut le savoir écrire il a dû eux
il a dû attendre un non mais c'est pas
grave
ne t'inquiète pas un
essayez la chope espions et du coup va
choper g7 mais c'est pas clair du tout
c'est pas clair du tout il joue pas mal
un matisse live pas mal en a marre jouez
mal qu'on voulait contre moi je jouais
mal quand vous voulez contre moi les
amis alors partir à la veille sur
l'essai de prendre ça est de repartir
car là bas et que ça quand même
l'avantagé de nous faire un pion de plus
maintenant
avec une meilleure avec une meilleure
position droit bloc le roi adverse on
menace qui est hissé 4
la ceni calme maintenant on a réussi à
choper les pions et ça gagne tout seul
elle était pas mauvais un baromètre a
bon dos dames non
allez hop c'est gagné il a été bon a plu
pin à tort pour le pin à tort alors ce
que ça donne il est fort il est fort
aussi à ils sont tous formats marc
agents et super marre j'en ai super mari
fou tous bien y en a pas un qui joue mal
ça devient lourd
franchement ça devient lourd sans trame
devenir très lourd bon alors poutine a
tort
je vois les gens qui ont vu à classroom
assassination dans le chat et bien voilà
enfin des gens qui ont un peu de culture
dans ce chat quand même
j'aime bien c'est un pied bien rayon
caillan coup on te retiens très bien
très bien très bien très bien
non mais on a réussit pas on réussit pas
à rattraper un ces problématiques un bon
là on rattrape notre pions et puis on a
une position gagnante mais on n'y arrive
pas
il y en a marre n'y en a marre super
froid chez moi en plus je sais pas la
salle ce tournoi est trop compliqué pour
moi est trop difficile trop difficile
c'est trop difficile
allez lui faire les pions à lui faire un
point intermédiaire y en a marre de page
ou deux points intermédiaires
je suis heureux d'enfin point
intermédiaire au moins j'ai fait un
point intermédiaire dans ma vie quoi
allez on va se placer pas très malin
cette histoire d'ailleurs peu importe
à tenter un truc marrant
alors peut faire tour des 5 et gagné une
pièce et gagner la partie on va faire un
truc plus drôle qui peut tout autant
gagner ce qu'on a essayé de le mater on
a ça 3 mater sur ces trois on va faire
b3 et à 3 matches
ouais je pense pas qu'ils puissent
sortir du mat c'est plus marrant on va
après move à 3 ce cas c'est assez beau
pas aimé ça marche pas
c'est impressionnant c'est
impressionnant c'est impressionnant
c'est impressionnant je m'auto
impressionne de nullité quoi je crois
enfin prouver que la stupidité n'a pas
de limite pas qu'à ces captures français
4 est normalement tu abandonnes je
l'espère assez ridicule c'est ridicule
c'est riddick
c'est ridicule c'est ridicule je suis
tellement un idiot quoi je suis
complètement perdre en main non
affublé de faire marcher ce avec une
taxi tour des quatre qui prend ses 3
pour m'en sortir c'est mon quotidien
j'avais mal aux échecs c'est mon
quotidien bienvenue dans ma vie
welcome to my life j'en parle en anglais
quoi
l on remonte
ils sont forts qui sont forts ils sont
forts en avoir cassé le manche est né à
s'est pas passé pour pinatar s'est pas
passé comme on rattrapera pas on a on a
quinze points de retard sur le leader
c'est la loi des plus petits classement
dans l'arena mais pourtant fait pas un
si mauvais truc en a perdu qu'une partie
contre et année on a fait un nul au
début un peu trop trop laid c'est vrai
mais mais sinon là on est sur une série
de 10 victoires quand même d'affilée pas
si mal
je viens de craquer à la fin
heureusement il y en avait marre
bon c'est la catastrophe a là encore
c'est encore la catastrophe adac je vois
plus rien paraît que je rejoue
normalement que je me remette à jouer
normalement aux échecs là ça craint trop
mais après ça me faire mal jouer dans
d'autres tournois de faire ça mais c'est
pas bon ça instaure delà
c'est la catastrophe la ok ça va pas
surtout les gens au chat comprennent que
je fais plus ou moins exprès de le faire
ça
de troller bon allez
ça va partir
ma main puis séduire par un avion pour
moi jouer ses positions assez dur en ce
sens où normalement au niveau les gens
ils abandonnent la crème faf
c'est juste difficile intellectuellement
de réfléchir là vraiment raté n'était
pas voulu bon soit en rien à gagner à
ouais enfin un set partout j'ai fait nul
est celle où j'ai perdu j'ai trois les
condés mec est également assez bon un
hoquet dans gilda position était
complètement gagnante et dans l'autre
contre ethan hawke et je sais pas si
j'aurais gagné la seule je sais pas si
j'aurais gagné en jouant normal la
deuxième partie c'est le contre et tan
tan ça aurait fait nul état ne s'est pas
sûr que je l'aurais battu mais bon tu
sois gens dans le chatt genre tu joues
pas bien en quoi oui mais c'est sûr que
c'est mais vous savez que le second
degré n'est pas forcément de facile donc
allez on en voit aller on en voit allez
c'est parti
là ça va bien se passer ne t'inquiète
pas ça va bien se passer bien se passer
ne t'inquiète pas allez allez est pas
mal ce pion et a laissé trois dames
français 4 j'avais annoncé 1
j'avais annoncé
j'avais annoncé le piège il a marché
allez on continue là il faut il faut
monter la faux faux regagner une partie
vite
amina les allées faut jouer vite là d'un
grand dessein et louis malle est ok c3
c4
allez on va faire tous ces quatre baies
3 on peut envoyer
créé des menaces allez allez à là il
faut jouer vite faut gagner vite là
ça en fait jordan je pense que tu
comprends vraiment pas feinte et
complètement tu renvoies le second degré
en fait pas de chance pour toi voir les
à la mine
c'est un fait j'ai pas compris enfin
futur est fait avant et puis je prendre
b4
il a dû penser qu'ils avaient joué six
ne peut pas abandonner
ok ça c'est gagné à l'arrière partie il
faut qu'on enchaîne faut qu'on enchaîne
les victoires là on le gagne quand même
ce soir je veux avoir mon mon abonnement
diamant c'est pas terrible rc4 et puis
on prend ces 6 7 1 fallait faire le 5
d'abord
qu'est-ce pas mal joué il vaut mieux de
son lots matisse lorsque ça donne
jusqu'au bout quand même mais pour le
moment il joue pas mal à sortir des
caves à lyon essaie de venir en d3 et ça
peut payer ça peut payer paye un petit
échec quand même
elle a un petit d'anne decis life parce
qu'elle y perd tactique comme position
est ce que matisse va résister
honnêtement je pense par ailleurs tu
comprends f3 fou prend b6 échec qui
comprend deux échecs et puis on prend b6
et mathis qui s'est fait raser deux
pièces pas de chance il s'en est pas
rendu compte là là il est en train de
réaliser matisse
j'ai perdu deux pièces allez c'est pas
mal c'est pareil on a rasé deux pièces à
matisse à les poulpes et n'attends rien
a marre de jeu contre aucune à tort
c'est pas possible pour le pin à tort
enfin c'est plus possible de jouer
contre toi on la nuit en sueur presque à
l'infini nation ne sait pas on ne sait
pas est ce que quelqu'un le sait
tu vas voir appeler alexandre astier
pour lui demander quoi est-ce que
matisse et de ta famille on ne sait pas
alors pour le pin à tort qu est ce qui
me donne la popeline à tort par y en a
marre de jouer contre toi poutine à tort
j'en peux plus
trop fort et trop fort pinatar il est
trop fort pour moi pour le pin à tort
j'en ai marre j'en peux plus
j'en peux plus de ce pool pinata
j'en peux plus heureusement qu'il a fait
un petit biscuit qui voulait faire h3 et
c'est bien fait pour lui ça te fera les
pieds pour pina tort à l'ascension des
tactiques ridicule à il y en avoir de
spleen à tort
alors à temps elle va faire un truc
marrant pas si ça a fonctionné un
salaire de fonctionner des masses mais
bon pourquoi que je pensais qu'il avait
protégé quand même ce serait super mal
placé mais ça passe ça passe ça passe ça
va passer les mecs
voilà c'est passé de justesse ça soit si
on peu près move dans le pro tour
plonger sa copine à tort voilà enfin il
ya tenté le coup jusqu'au bout un as et
insupportable il est insupportable qui
n'a tort
il est insupportable
amine en sueur aller à est insupportable
il a été insupportable je vais t'appeler
poopy du coin c'est le bon son de pupi
il est dur cependant pin à tort il est
fort à et l'effort il est trop fort
c'est le plus bas des échecs
c'est le bon sens de poule qui est
nouveau premier mais bon faut continuer
de vivre on joue un peu sérieux on a 15
sur 15
il faut continuer on se met trop long
trop le plus hot en interne ses titres
au trône et surtout la première en fait
encore contre contre et annie mérité ça
nul
l'état ne méritait ça nul mais
mais contre française man j'ai quand
même abusé dès le début à les bulles on
en voit et on en voit en moi dit il
après après s'être promis de ne plus
trop les noms mais ça va ça paraisse pas
trop pourri ça comme sacrifice je pense
ça passe ça passe droit à l'abri
on envoie c'est ton affaire d'un rêve
cette dame h5 à you want to be loved by
you voilà yoko ono bayou
bah voilà
et ben voilà mines et ben voila quand il
veut a minima des pièces en un va voi la
mine les merci merci tonton la petite
pièce en un qui faisait plaisent en plus
et les menaces de fourrage de maths dans
dans l'enchaînement et ben voilà à 1009
de ie9 de easy qui s'est fait mettre en
place par carrie cela tonton tonton je
suis le padre du rap game
allez on est reparti allez donnez moi
des appariements là et on enchaîne un
minot sueur allez les tontons allez
donnez moi donner donner devant les
voilà l'a pareillement qui fait plaisir
contre acura si bim acura si la curation
sueur boom il faut 5 allez hop on va le
gagner ce sont à ce sera peut-être une
des plus plus plus beau résultat de ma
carrière quoi dégager tous dégager tout
ce sera peut-être un des meilleurs
moments de ma carrière et chicken et
c'est la vérité les amibes away logique
logique
allez les tontons on y va tout temps
tout en finesse on va lui prendre son
pion s'il fait h 3 bis mal et on lui
prend son pion ça j'avais pas vu
l'image choquait franchement je suis
choquée j'ai trois je suis choqué
franchement je suis choqué franchement
je suis choqué je suis choqué par son
coût franchement elle m'a choqué h3c
reste est venu comme moi c'est nul comme
une révélation ce que je croise yeux
pour masser c'est vraiment venu comme
une révélation quoi l'imam a choqué je
pense qu'il m'a fait passer pour une
mère donjon h3
c'est arrivé m'a surpris positivement
quoi je me suis dit c'est là que tu
comprends que tu as rien compris aux
échecs tard mais qu'ils arrivent tous à
tout chaussures acura sibout mis une
claque sérieux et m'a mis une claque là
sérieux il m'a mis une claque
acura si tu m'a mis une claque je te
félicite
dans mes g3 ça m'a choqué même moi
j'aurais pas été capable d'un coup
pareil tu vois j'ai été la jeune fille
non mais franchement les mecs
franchement un mec qui vous fait j'ai
trois comme ça en partie franchement tu
as quasiment vides abandonnées
j'ai 4 ans ok je m'incline quasiment
devant le génie quoi là si tu veux il
m'a vraiment mis une claque quoi il m'a
mis une claque à chaud chaud chaud
chocolat nord mais c'est une chanson à
cons là le truc au chocolat et c'est un
truc qui passe à la radio là
naïma show qui arrivera ici
ouais le g4 est encore plus beau non
mais j'ai pris une claque et chicken
dans cette partie des trucs chocolat les
gens ces gens se se rappelle pas de
cette chanson près avec le moi qui
connais voilà
ah ouais c'est l'artisan a émis nikon
est complètement con cette chanson
j'adore je préviens tout de suite il
fait qu avait lieu saint juif et d'en
prendre cinq ans la marque
non non j'en ai eu marre j'ai eu envie
de gagner l'aréna quoi désolé les mecs
je m'excuse quoi
ouais c'est l'artiste c'est ça
alors cette dame de moins
contre citron chocolat
bon pour le moment c'est pas top qui on
va prendre une fois on va faire ses
quatre filles et quatre échecs ma
chambre
ok mais fou 17 prises roi prend ces
pourris il prend maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont forts invoquée mais ils sont
trop forts peut aller mais qui me fait
un chèque chaque avec le fou tu avais
jamais pensé à ce truc là bas mais j'ai
compris ces deux problèmes se tournant
ils sont trop forts
il ya trop de skill du fou j'avais pas
du tout enfin
ils sont trop avancé pour moi je laisse
h7 pas ce que je fais 3 h 8 et en fait
j'ai même pas pourquoi
là il joue bien et je joue bien et roy e
2 est tout j'en ai marre françois jacq 1
j'en peux plus quoi j'en peux plus de
ces gens j'en peux plus j'en ai marre il
prend pas ça être mais bon à y sacrifier
la qualité qu'est ce que c'est bientôt
et qu'est ce que c'est bien joli mais
pour h7
non mais ils sont trop forts qui sont
trop forts
tours à trois ça ces gens aussi fort il
va falloir fort être encore plus fort il
va falloir plus fort qu'eux
face à ceux déjà en une telle force faut
être plus fort arrêt choqué choqué
batroun et je suis choqué par leur force
franchement ils sont trop forts pour moi
bon là ça va ça se passe pas trop mal
mais ça n'empêche qui m'a choqué bah
c'est quand même pas trop mal passé au
final ça on a géré
soit un reflux en d4 ça aurait été mieux
grâce à face à fonctionne pas mon truc
mon truc fonctionne pas je lis dans l'os
ça c'est cool genk à l'option citron
chocolat
bon ça
il n'y a pas de double attaque ça va
tout protéger allez je couvre tout
sortez couverts sèche protégés j'ai
regroupé toutes mes pièces
ça va je me sens bien ça va ça va aller
mais je crois qu'on va gagner le tournoi
je crois qu'on va ça y est je pense que
ce soir ça va être la fête les tontons
on va fêter on va on va fêter notre plus
belle victoire les mecs ce soir
je crois qu'on va pouvoir fêter d'un
plus belles victoires les amis on n'est
pas loin là on n'est pas loin
crash n'est pas cette chanson de callas
criminelle
mais bon ça je gère je gère je gère
ça va je suis fou prend d'ailleurs
comment on fait pour rejoindre je veux
être le lien mais là le 3 saghand en
huit minutes 1 allez on est pas mal
là on est pas mal on est pas mal
franchement dans cette partie on est pas
mal pas mal de faire un math en fait
je pas de maths direct je trouve pas de
maths forcé
je trouve pas de maths forcer les amis
positionner pas trop mauvaise à les
abandonner a les a suivis à nice à on a
presque fini le tournoi
allez on va se faire plein et bien
écoutez ça aurait été dur et fatigant
franchement vous m'aurez fatigués les
mecs sur tous les gamins là est tanné
bobby fischer là je passe il encore là
où me fischer mef
ils m'ont fatigués les 2 1
allez bim
ont forcé à m'arrêter de troller en fait
ils m'ont forcé à arrêter trolls et les
gamins incroyable
ils sont incorrigibles issou
en force à enchaîner les victoires
incroyables
non mais reconnaissez qu'ils ont été
insupportable quand même dans le tchat
j'espère au moins qu'on est d'accord là
dessus très insolente ray insolent
j'avais très agitée dessus trésorière
fait tour à froid ici un pour protéger
mon truc
je suis très mal mais je suis très
heureux
bah oui et toujours la ligne 2 0 à
l'état n'est pas premier ouais mais en
fait j'ai changé d'avis à un moment
donné j'ai arrêté troll pour gagner en
fait j'ai trop les un long moment et au
monde au défi n'en faut quand même que
je gagne en a marre et du coup quand
j'ai décidé de gagner ben tu vois je
suis 10 9 sur 19 coiffe fait le point et
demi que j'ai perdu quand même utilisé
j'aurais pu avoir je pourrais avoir 22
et demi sur sur 23 comme glisse celle
contre et anne je suis pas sûr que je
l'aurais gagné donc je veux pas dire un
truc que j'ai raté la passe qui est
juste à me ccap tête je suis pas sur
celle contre état ne suis pas sûr que
j'aurais gagné
voilà
qu'est ce que c'est que cette position
c'est spécial c'est marrant il ya tout
cas en prise balle et je rajoute des
pièces emprise c'est génial il ya tout
l'échiquier emprise fantastique
c'est très amusant pas à ça m'amuse
beaucoup abrège face à mu mon adversaire
mais c'est génial
la position n'a aucun intérêt quoi c'est
complètement ridicule
c'est beau quoi cette position tellement
dans l'esprit des talents magnifique
cette position elle est tellement
magnifique cette position qui affaire
d'âme pranger de baby boom et boum et
bout le retour du beau jeu quoi pour
finir c'est tellement fantastique
bim bim bim isde il n'y a pas d'âme f7
match j'ai protégé
pas de chance la chambre klaï adam
gadahn des huit matches lâche en clash
en cloud est allé on finit par je vais
gagne allez on finit par ont fini par
par bobby fischer
ce n'est par bobby fischer marre de ces
gamins ont leurs joues à la fin quand on
boit le calice jusqu'à la lie quoi
vraiment on boit le calice jusqu'à la
lie pour finit par un gamin quand il y
en a marre
arbitre il vraiment humiliée quoi ils
jouent une grotte enfin
ils sont vraiment insupportable j'en
peux plus j'en peux plus de ces enfants
je n'en peux plus ils sont vraiment
insupportable ils sont vraiment
insupportable pas mon nos gros biffi pas
un mètre de la grotte attendait mais
quand même j'ai quand même bossé mois
pour en arriver là
voilà je vais là-bas la grotte ça ça va
pas été apporté sur un plateau d'argent
j'ai envie de te dire dame prend des
trois d'un projet à chaque intermédiaire
et puis on prend
robe longue robe ici pas n'importe qui
j'ai envie de dire je suis devenu maître
grotte quand même en bas il ya les
maîtres course et à mettre grob voilà on
va pas réussir à la finir ce qu'on n'a
pas assez de temps
dommage dommage c'est très dommage
c'est très dommage mon écoute et on en
aura on aura arrêté de troller on aura
fini avec un autre petit vin sur main
c'est la suprématie je pensais qu'ils
allaient gagner 1 était bien parti puis
finalement on a quand même réussi à
enchaîner les victoires pour ma fille
est confirmée 22h30 sur 24 mais bon
comme mon frère 23 et demi mais bon tant
pis avec un physique a fait 18 sur 21
du coup 13 sur 16 13 me wade n'aurait pu
faire mieux mais bon c'était marrant
c'est amusant j'espère que ça vous amuse
évidemment c'était du second degré mais
est ce que tout le monde sera capable de
le comprendre on ne sait pas